hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
June 19 2023
what's going on
how are ya
happy Juneteenth to everybody
I'm going to be Billy liberal today
happy Juneteenth to everybody both the
descendants of former slaves and the
descendants of former slave masters
because if it wasn't for those
oppressors then we wouldn't have this
holiday
um I'm [__] with you oh and and happy
uh Happy pride month
to uh all the gay people but more
importantly all these straight people
that just cannot stop complimenting
themselves about how many gay friends
they have
um I believe you call them my gays
oh there's so many people that [__]
annoy me they really do ugh
you know you know those people who like
uh remember on MySpace
or Facebook I'm going way back in social
media you know
do you remember way back during a
simpler time on MySpace like every
[__]
dummy had to say I have a very eclectic
music taste my music tastes are very
eclectic I don't know who wrote that and
then everybody saw it and then everybody
has to go [__] do it and it's like
literally
um
it's the inverse of what the [__]
word means right oh
eclectic means a wide variety and I'm
saying you're a hack that isn't right
all right whatever it's kind of like you
know how this like social media jokes
and everybody does them to the point of
like how the [__] do you still think
that this is a [__]
like I was joking about that last night
on stage where like you know
um
every [__] video it's like tell me
you're a construction worker without
telling me you're a construct tell me
you're a [__] diss without telling me
to tell me all right we get it
Jesus [__] Christ
foreign
oh that's a joke [__] uh um what'd
you call that a joke structure that
works I'm gonna use it
like Mad Libs I'm just gonna change the
uh thing oh Bill what are you looking
down your [__] nose is that what
you're doing your cute little butt nose
I do have a cute little button nose no I
wouldn't say a button nose but it is
adorable
um
anyway all of that [__] yeah so then
like they call them uh they call them my
gays
you know
I love the gays
like what the [__] does that even mean
just generally just straight across the
[__] board
you know
there's no [__] in the gay community
all right whatever
anyway happy pride month to gay people
and [__] all those straight people that
that Acquire gay friends like [__] uh
I don't know like people that coll
collect things
sorry I don't know what my deal is I
just [__] woke up you know what it is
my son
gets up every morning now at about 4 30
5 and he just comes walking into the
room it used to be three now it's like
five because walking and he goes and he
just like a middle of the afternoon
voice just go Dada I want breakfast
dada
ain't no egg sandwich
no egg sandwich I don't know why he puts
no in front of every sentence
no water please
dada
he starts
slap man died no water please I'm like
buddy it's too early
so then I gotta take them back to his
room
he gets into his bed and then I get in
the adult bed that's in there so he
doesn't leave again and then what he
does is he crawls in the bed and for the
next like whatever 90 minutes two hours
he doesn't stop moving around
kick it kicking kicking singing songs
excavator hey dirt see you waiter for
like I don't know but someday I'll miss
it so
I'm a little a little off my game I'm
also off my game because uh
my wife's birthday my son's birthday my
birthday and Father's Day are all jammed
in and
um in this month and everybody just
sends over like cupcakes and cookies my
wife came home she had somebody get
giving us a friggin banana cream pie
and uh it's like don't these people
realize I'm a fat [__] like what are we
doing here so
I kind of had to like uh
yeah somebody sent over vegan cookies or
anything [__] worse than vegan
cookies because it's like you're still
gonna eat them and they don't even taste
good
you just like uh you know you're just
trying to work your way through the
cookie to like the chocolate chip
like I don't even know what do you mean
vegan it's like you [__] gotta kill a
cow
to make a cookie do you you take some of
its milk and then you have an egg that's
just an unfertilized [__]
egg right
wait a minute is an egg a chicken having
its period
I gotta look this up
that is so [__] bizarre
and if women laid eggs instead of past
them would they be less grumpy
is an egg egg
chickens I'm literally this is gonna be
on my search
chickens period oh that wasn't
that wasn't that it came up people
people have asked us not just me all
right although chickens do not
menstruate
and thus their eggs are not chicken
periods as is sometimes asserted the
cycle of creating and passing much
larger eggs relative to their body size
and weight is arguably even more
physically tasking especially in modern
hens who have been bred to produce such
unnaturally
wait a minute
what is a period for a hen the
incubation period for the chickens eggs
is 20 to 21 days and increases up to 30
days for other poultry after sitting for
some days a Broody hen can be given some
newly hatched chicks and if they are
accepted the original eggs can be
removed dude I I am like my head is so
[__] spinning right now
all right so I still the rooster still
has to bang a chicken to make a chicken
right they're not like self-sustained
units are they
and when the chicken that the rooster
bangs the chicken like how does the
semen get through that hard shell of the
egg
how the [__] do you make an egg in you
that doesn't seem like a natural thing
it's just too many questions all right
whatever
all I know about eggs is that I eat them
and they're delicious I have little soft
cooked egg machine that I make and I'm
drinking right now lemon water
because I got back on the sugar but now
I'm done you just drink some lemon water
in the morning and then that's it and
then you just do [__] I'm talking to
myself not to you guys then you just
have a handful of peanuts and a piece of
fruit and then you [__] you're right
as rain
because you know you know what I've been
watching on the uh on the Netflix there
is there's a documentary on Arnold
Schwarzenegger and it's one of the most
motivating things
I've ever watched in my life I mean that
guy truly is one of the most amazing
like as far as public figures goes
you know making something of yourself
ice long time ago
I did a bit about that you know when
people were you know when he was going
through his personal life [__] right
which is none of my business
everybody was making fun of them it's
like oh yeah do you think you could move
to Austria learn the language
when their highest bodybuilding
competition like six seven years in a
[__] row and then use that to somehow
start an acting career before anybody
had ever done that
and then become a [__] movie star
and then transcend your typecasted
[__]
you know roles as an action hero
to then do a comedy
and start doing comedies and then you
could basically do anything be
Kindergarten Cop and after a while
people forget your Transylvanian accent
and then when you're done with that you
marry into America's royalty the Kennedy
family and you start a political career
and you become governor of California
right you think you could [__] how
many lifetimes would you I would need at
least I don't know
30.
in some of those dreams would never come
true
even if I Juiced I don't have the
[__] height
but like when he just sat there talking
about working out
he goes you get a picture in your mind
and then you will the body to become
that picture something like that
I've always had a Clear Vision
if I can see it then I can be it I can
achieve it
and it was just
he's sitting in his [__] hot tub
smoking a cigar
I love this house
it's the combination of who I am it's
the house has the warmth of Austria
and then
what did he say he said the the flavor
of America
big
and I like that he loves animals
and he has like a he has like a donkey
or something that that he loves and
everybody like looks past the donkey and
I guarantee you that he sees something
in that donkey some sort of Drive some
sort of will that he can relate to and
he Vibes with that donkey the way that
things never vibed with another [__]
Hume most human beings look at him as
something to carry their carts drag
their carts around right some people in
some parts of the world they use it to
keep the [__] I guess the the
the other livestock com it's sort of the
sort of the Bob Probert I saw one
[__] up a hyena which I didn't think
was possible I don't know how it grabbed
it by the back of its neck and it just
kept slamming it down on the ground and
it wouldn't [__] let go in the
[__] hyena
I think because hyenas they they don't
like they're not like cats they don't
like
what the [__] I'm so confused what the
animals say what the [__] is a hyena
it's one of those weird animals
where it's it's not everything I feel
like is either a cat or a you know like
like a like part of the lion and tiger
family or like a wolf
when it comes to those sort of
four-legged things then you just got
these hybrid things like a hyena well I
guess you got Bears too I [__] hate
bears
[__] can't stand like just the the
extra [__]
disgusting way they have to kill things
you know
I do love watching them run though it
always looks like a fat guy coming down
a hill
this like she's you know you ever see a
fact I start running down a hill and
then the arms get going like the bear
has that too there's something about
them that they look like slightly out of
control it's like watching F1 highlights
in the 1950s when they had the open
cockpit and they were driving those
little two seaters like right at the
[__] limit with those baloney skin
[__] tires that's what it's like
watching a goddamn bear run down the
hill so anyways I have a giant vat of
lemon water that's supposed to be good
to drink in the morning but then if you
drink too much of it it [__] eats
away your enamel so you can't do it
every day the enamel on your teeth man
it's just I mean
it's just like we're designed to get to
our Peak
and then
immediately start dying that's what I I
feel like it is so I am well past my
Prime
physically but as a person I like to
think I just keep getting better I just
feel like there's a better version of me
and when it's me and I'm hanging out
with my gay friends and their job is to
sit around me and tell me how fabulous I
look so I'll continue to buy them tight
shirts
um
all right I don't know what I'm talking
about here you got to watch the Arnold
Schwarzenegger documentary
adult all right it was it's like
um he's like a giant Tom Cruise because
Tom Cruise is another guy that I watch
and I just sit there
you know
watching like what that guy did like
have you seen the Billboards for the new
Mission Impossible I mean this is a guy
that's in his 60s and he's riding a
[__] dirt bike off a cliff and then
pulling
pulling a reserved shoot or pulling a
chute is parachute I mean
like that level like why just look at
that I'm like what what and where in my
life am I that dedicated
because I look at that billboard and I
filed that all under I'm not doing that
[__] I'm not [__] doing that [__]
that's what you got a stunt man for
I mean I'll ride the dirt bike around
the parking lot you know maybe get a
second
Billy dangerous maybe in third gear but
then that's it then somebody's gonna
come running over and be like Bill
you're too bald and fragile get off that
thing and I'll be like you know what
you're right I 100 understand that
um you know what I also understand is
that your Boston Red Sox swept the New
York Yankees this weekend whoa two game
sweep
because the other game got rained out
you know there was a [__] up game that
got away from the Yankees that was a uh
that was the 15-5 game when Justin
Turner had like [__] 48 RBIs you know
making us gingers look good are us
bearded gingers
I was worried he was going to be a yet
another
[__] giant third baseman that we
signed after they've he's won a World
Series and then comes here remember we
had that guy the panda panda pants
whatever his name was
and he [__] came to to Boston and he
immediately
went to the Kowloon and got some crab
rangoon and then he had a [__]
lobster roll and went to Bill and Bob's
roast beef and he never [__] played
again
it's actually a sad story when I look at
that I actually think that the guy he
probably grew up
in poverty and was always hungry I
always felt that way about that Raiders
quarterback
you know unless it was just total
self-sabotage I just think there's
there's
um the books that I've read
about growing up like that and just
constantly having that Pang of hunger in
your stomach
one of the most brutal books I ever read
was Angela's Ashes
a classic Irish tale of disappointment
sadness starvation and alcoholism and
every [__] week waiting for the dad
to come home with the paycheck and the
guy would go directly to the pub and
drink it all away and it was just brutal
uh anyway Happy Father's Day everybody
[Laughter]
um
oh but getting back to that I am I'm
full in on the uh I'm back into baseball
so I'm excited we got the twins this
week
and uh
I've also you know I've watched the last
two motogp's I didn't talk about the
previous one the one in Italy because it
was kind of uneventful
other than Mark Marquez crashing again
and then this one in Germany was like
this is the best race I've seen since
the classic days my classic days of what
I always talk about uh Marquez versus
Vizio so
um Jorge Martine versus uh Pekka beignet
just passing each other back and forth I
mean there was basically six one
hundredths of a second between the two
of them incredible race
Ducati swept first second and third
and unfortunately Mark Mark has like
crashed two or three times before the
race even started you know
um on like Saturday or something like
that Friday and Saturday I have no idea
broke a bone in his thumb and he just
said I'm not racing
and uh
I can't believe the level of hate that
people have for Mark Marquez and I think
it really is because he's the guy that
showed all of these um
fans of what's his face
why am I spacing on everybody's name
number 46 the doctor
um
Valentino Rossi there we go Jesus Christ
Valentino Rossi I think that they
he kind of showed them that Valentino
wasn't going to be the last great one
greatest one of all time and they were
worried that he was going to come along
and win more titles and do whatever he
might have I have no idea but like the
level of [__] hate for Mark Marquez
is [__] ridiculous the guy is so
great for the sport I don't want to see
him keep crashing I don't know if it's
the [__] my a buddy of mine who
really watches the sports trying to say
it's the bike
um
but Jesus Christ
he slammed into uh Joanne zarco
literally cut his [__] bike in half
everybody was going if it was a little
bit you know
different position he could Joanne could
have lost his [__] leg you forget
that sometimes it's the scariest thing
about riding a bike
it's not dying because then you're dead
but [__] just like losing your
goddamn leg
[__] all of that all right that was my
in-depth analysis of
whatever I just [__] enjoy it I think
the bikes are gorgeous I love how fast
they're [__] going and uh I love how
it's International all right there
that's my level of it I'm too afraid to
ride a motorcycle unless I'm on a track
going 30 miles an hour wearing full
[__] gear
um
anyway
uh so the Red Sox now I think are two
games above 500 we still two games below
I have no idea and we're in last place
but it is fun I gotta tell you it's fun
to see oh we're two games above 500.
it's fun to see the [__] Orioles are
good
this is such a good year in sports the
Denver Nuggets are the NBA champions the
Vegas Knights of the Stanley Cup
champions
I'd love to see the Orioles win their
first one since 83.
or [__] uh I'm so it's like I like I
hate how ESPN
like they always do the Yankees went and
all is right in baseball it's like
you're so like institutionalized that
you feel like that these like only the
Lakers should be in the finals only the
Reds uh the Yankees should be in the
[__] or uh there's like three four
teams in baseball three four teams in um
basketball that seemed to be acceptable
like oh I'll watch that and if they
don't I'm not watching the NBA finals
um
that's why I think hockey and NFL are
are better run leagues although I'm
[__] pissed at the NFL right now that
they're moving their product over to
YouTube right I don't give a [__] that
they're doing that
but the fact that they sit there going
like yeah you don't have to put some
satellite dish up on your house it's
like hey hey you [__] [__] weren't
you guys weren't saying that [__] when I
when I had to do it
when you signed with DirecTV you acted
like that was a great thing now you walk
away from them that's a bad look
you know what that's like that's like
trash in your ex it's just a bad [__]
look all right wish her well wish him
well
and you just [__] move on you know
you don't do that [__] [__] sitting
there not you know I'm sitting there I I
got a
I got a dish on top of my [__] house
and now the NFL's pulling up Stakes
they're moving over to YouTube and then
you're going to turn around and make fun
of me because I got a dish on my house
no it's like it's a really [__] thing
with that that they're doing here where
it's like they're acting like like I
always say rollerblade they're acting
like they never rollerbladed you did
rollerblade you set up the cones you
know you had pink leg warmers on you did
your little backwards [__] tricks in
Central Park I saw you
I [__] saw you do it and now you're
gonna act like you never did it and
you're gonna hope that the whole fad
[__] goes away
like they're rooting against DirecTV so
now I have to get YouTube TV and this is
what I do I never cancel my other [__]
because I can't be bothered with it
because the most effective way to do it
is online so I think now I'm gonna be
paying about 400 a month
probably I gotta get some tech person to
come over here and and streamline
my my cable TV
satellite TV
online [__]
because like I am I am subscribed
to Netflix
DirecTV
uh
Roku
Amazon
YouTube Prime
I just keep wanting to watch these
movies and they're not available
anywhere else and I'm like well you got
to sign up for this [__] that's like all
right
and I sign up for it then I forget that
I that I I I'm Paramount
pair my plus I'm on HBO I got all of
this [__]
ah when I was a kid it was all on the
idiot box
I did the Roxy last night
legendary place I uh getting the hour
ready because I'm going out to Allentown
and [__] Hershey Pennsylvania and out
in [__] New Jersey I'm gonna be ready
so I'm doing the Troubadour the
Troubadour tonight
another legendary music venue and uh I'm
so excited to do these gigs and I I'm
working with a different set of comics
each night I went out and I deliberately
you know book comedians in front of me
that really inspire me because I I I
can't even tell you how excited I get
when I see a young comic that I know is
going to be great and that they're kind
of doing like some different [__] and
all of that and uh
I had a great time last night I worked
with uh Bianca christophile and faheem
Anwar and they [__] killed it
and uh that's another thing too that I
like is it's a nice variety and people
already get a good show before I even
get up there so I feel like the crowd's
already going to be in a good mood so
um
I think I'm gonna do this more often
like just sort of go into places like
that
because I love The Comedy Store and I
always
gonna love it and everything but every
once in a while to just switch up the
background to be standing in a different
venue kind of just put you in a
different headspace like I was like you
know when I was at the Roxy last night
um
I was of course thinking you know Sam
Kinison taped the special here now I got
to look that up Jesus Christ I'm looking
up [__] chickens I still don't
understand that
wait snakes [__] I know I've seen that
so
and they lay eggs it's got to be how it
works
am I Really Gonna Google how does a
rooster's jizz get through the hard
shell of an egg it's got a fur no
it's got to start off where it's just
the egg and then a shell grows around it
my God the [__] heartburn a chicken
must have any reptile that you lay eggs
um what was I looking up Sam
Kinison the Roxy
special
let's see here
yeah 1984.
let's see IMDb let me see IMDb boom
Sam Kinison Breaking the Rules
let's see here uh
is that amazing and he just filmed it
that that gigantic
icon of a comedian film that legendary
special in in that little Club
where is it
that doesn't happen here yeah April 21st
1987 at least that's when it came out
yeah that was one that put them over the
top so I was thinking about that I was
thinking about all the bands that I've
seen at the Roxy everybody that I heard
that have played there and then tonight
go down to the Troubadour I remember
hearing Steve Martin telling a story
about doing stand-up at the Troubadour
like co-headlining with Richard Pryor
and how Richard Pryor you know he went
up and he did his thing and then got off
stage and then Richard showed up like 45
minutes later and came in and
immediately like won the crowd over and
Steve Martin was amazed by that and all
that type of stuff but like they've
performed there and then that whole
Laurel Canyon
like singer-songwriter you know
everybody from uh
I still say the Eagles I guess it's just
Eagles
um that's another thing from Steve
Martin's book he was talking to one of
the members of the band and they said
we're putting we're putting together a
band and he goes what's it called and he
goes Eagles and Steve was going the
Eagles he's like no just Eagles
so Jackson Brown
um
Frank Zappa
Joni Mitchell all of them and they all
came down there Carol King Elton John
had a big I think showcase there
when that [__] David geffener somebody
saw him all of that all of that history
is there so I will come down there
um
I saw uh was it
what the [__] comedian I saw down
there
I've seen a couple comments down there
my what the [__] is going on my brain
today anyway I'm gonna be down there
staggering through my my uh my set
evidently
um
and uh I forget who I'm working with
tonight
who is tonight I know Dean's there Dean
Del Rey definitely has to be there
because Dean played there when he
fronted his band
he played their opening for guys
um oh the original lineup of Guns and
Roses
played there there's like pictures of
them there like all the way back to when
Steven Adler had that white drum kit
before he got the Black Pearl kit that
was on
um
that was on uh
what did they play they played in New
York the Ritz
then they played the Ritz and Dean was
telling me there is a
a new video that just surfaced it was
one of the last times it was the
original five
of that band one of my favorite bands of
all time
um
and I also think part of it is because
as fans we had them for such a short
period
it was like they
I remember the album came out like
October 87.
and I was living in North Carolina and I
still remember where I was driving when
I heard Welcome to the Jungle and I and
I was like you know what I need a new
band I can't just keep listening to AC
DC these guys sound cool and I wasn't
even like overly excited about Welcome
to the Jungle I just was starting to
feel old and I didn't want to be left
behind it's funny I was 19. I was
starting to feel old
so I bought the cassette tape
and I started listening to it and I
don't always listen to the single
and then I would listen to uh
what was the next one on that
I see your sister in a Sunday dress I
would get through that one and then Mr
Brownstone and then I would stop and
then each time I would go deeper into
the album then finally I was like this
whole [__] album is great
and uh
and then I totally got into Stephen
Adler and he was my favorite drummer
from the 80s I just thought it was so
[__] badass that he had that little
kit and everybody else had these giant
[__] kits even if they didn't need
him he had a little four-piece [__]
kid the amount of goddamn I'm telling
you go back and listen to that [__]
album and the drum parts that that guy
comes up with
um the fills that are part of the groove
the floor tom patterns
um
just like the intro for
um Paradise City how that is just built
for an arena
like how that can just make 80 000
people lose their [__] mind and all
it is is flams on the snare and
syncopation with the bass drum that's a
boom
boom Oh dad that's all it is
has everybody going [__] nuts I mean
the genius of that
um
yeah so anyway I guess there's this new
video Dean was telling me
of them
I think playing some of the user
illusion material with the original five
before Izzy left and and unfortunately
Stephen got kicked out
and uh
I actually listened to this podcast 33
and a third with this guy had on Ricky
Rockman and Sebastian Bach and they were
talking about
the use your Illusion album
quite yet the quadruple album all came
out at the same [__] time
and uh
that was just such like a [__] show
during that period of Music where grunge
had already come in for like a couple of
years
so it was like moving forward and then
this band that was broken 87-88 that was
the biggest band of the late 80s
was now stomping their foot down on the
90s
um
I felt like I was like as a fan I was
kind of caught in the middle of all of
that [__] and uh
I was just like I can't listen to all of
this [__] and I just said [__] these
grunge pants
and I kept listening to [__] skid row
and all of that [__] and you know what
in that time was when I first became old
because then I didn't know like
everybody like say that Pearl Jam album
like 10 like they know it [__] front
to back and all I know is like the radio
jams because I never uh
to this day I still haven't bought that
album
although I will tell you I went back and
I listened to uh Jane's Addiction the
ritual album and
um
that second side that whole album you
want to talk about some of the most
original and beautiful drumming I've
ever [__] heard in my life
is on that album Stephen Perkins and his
[__]
um and then she did is that the name of
the song it has that beautiful like
ride pattern
and I always said man I'm going to sit
down one day I'm going to write that out
I'm going to [__] try and learn that
[__]
um I'm kind of all over the place right
now musically though because I um
I downloaded like all the Stevie Wonder
albums like those remember when he put
out like Five albums in five years
um and that was like his considered his
uh
I don't know what period they call that
the critics you know what I mean call it
but like he put out like some of the
best music of all time
on like five straight albums all working
towards the Masterpiece that his songs
in the key of life
and I've been listening to that and then
Queens of the Stone Age have a new album
and they're back out on the road
and I saw some live footage of them and
they opened with this song called Misfit
Love
if you're a drummer you gotta watch John
Theodore playing that although I don't
think he played the original
I think that was somebody else
um
but like
it's like open-handed drumming
and that's another one that's just it's
your right hand
on the rack and on the floor tom is why
am I giving you guys why am I telling
you this [__] I don't know I'm [__]
into it I saw that and I was like I
gotta download that album and I have to
learn how to [__] play that and
that's what I did on Father's Day
[Laughter]
so I went out to breakfast with my
lovely family and then I went down to
Long Beach
with my kids and uh we went to this
playground and went down by the ocean
and all that stuff
got myself a coffee we had a great time
we looked at some old cars
and came back then I hung out with my
lovely wife and then
I went out to the garage and I was like
I'm gonna try to learn how to [__]
play this and uh I failed miserably but
I had a great [__] time doing it all
right I'm just babbling
just [__] babbling here let me do the
uh let me do the the goddamn advertising
here that I haven't even set up
what's wrong with me is this it is this
the email okay here we go content oh
where did it go oh no
[Music]
all right here we go oh butcher box
everybody
you know it's getting harder and harder
that's what she said to control the
quality of food you feed yourself or
your family
isn't that the truth why isn't that
something that's outraging people
um did you see what Donald Trump said
our food is poison let's try to stay
keep your eye on the ball uh with
butcher box
um you can easily find high quality Meat
and seafood you can trust it's 100
grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken pork raised crate free and wild
caught Seafood you don't know what it's
gonna do humanely raise no antibiotics
or added hormones it gets delivered
right to your doorstep with free
shipping always and customized box plans
butcher Box gives you a variety of high
quality cuts at an amazing value with
exclusive member deals recipe
recipe what inspirate you mean
inspiration
I don't know what that word means
I also don't understand how chickens get
whatever guides tips and hacks butcher
box is giving us a special deal sign up
today
at butcherbox.com and use codebur to get
flank steak for free in every box for
three months plus twenty dollars off
your first order that's butcherbox.com
and use the code Burr to claim this deal
b-u-r-r oh and look who it is
our old friends
they've been here forever
you always there for me zip recruiter
excuse me you were always there for me
zip
um zip recruiter that's almost two and a
half months
so if you're hiring for whoa whoa whoa I
think I'm missing copy here it starts
off that's almost two and a half months
this is like a Tarantino movie where it
just kind of starts with some [__]
already happening then you're like
what's going on and then they [__]
Cuts back to stuff that happened before
it
are you talking about Pulp Fiction yeah
that's what I'm talking about all right
that's almost two and a half months so
if you're hiring for a growing business
do you really have that kind of time to
wait
all right so basically what they're
saying is if you go through some some
other [__] [__] ass
you know
job service by the time they get you a
client by the time they even get your
[__] going almost two and a half months
has passed all right so if you're hiring
for a growing business do you really
have that kind of time to wait I don't
think you do
unless your daddy's rich and he's
fronting it
um well if you're listening today I got
some advice for you stop waiting start
using Zippy
zip recruiter can help you find
qualified candidates for all your roles
fast and right now you can try you can
try for free at zip.com
ziprecruiter.com you can check out
people
you can check out the I'm getting
glasses people you can check out the
people that zip recruiters send you and
if you really like one or two you can
personally invite them to apply with one
click
which is great so then they feel wanted
and they know that they got a great
chance at getting hired so the whole
relationship starts off great
yeah which makes them apply even sooner
that's what I was trying to say plus
here's how quickly zip recruiter can
work to help you hire four to five
employ what here's how quickly zip
recruiter can work to help you hire
then it says four to five employers who
post on zipper crew to get a quality
candidate within the first day I don't
know what happened to this copy people
so speed up your hiring process with zip
recruiters Cy 3.8 million businesses
have come to zip
for hiring for their hiring needs just
go to this exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
again that's ziprecruiter.com spell
outbur b-u-r-r sip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
well I'll tell you what
I will [__] tell you what
it is time for a little bit of lemon
water
um
I saw this thing um
I saw this thing uh this Instagram video
of some white dude
I don't know where the [__] he was but
he was standing there
and he had a black lives matter sign
just standing on the side of the road so
of course he doesn't post the 18 000
people that drove by and didn't do
anything he posts all the people that
say like racist [__] and then people go
to America I know it's like no this is a
part of America
you know
I was actually sitting there looking at
people like how they could be that
[__] dumb and how they could get that
[__] worked up over a stupid [__]
sign while simultaneously eating food
that is literally poison
is a very
small group of people
are going to take control of the water
supply why the [__] you're concerned
with this [__]
you know what I mean
and then I realized because they go like
you know white lives matter too and I
realize like oh these are hurt people
they
have been left behind
and they also a lot of them are dumb
and I think when you're a dumb white
person all you have is that you're white
so you want to hang on to racism because
racism is sort of your affirmative
action that gives you a job you don't
deserve
over someone who isn't White
right I mean
I would love to hear your arguments on
that but that kind of feel like that's
what that is like I I've been doing this
bit I haven't figured out how to do it
but I was talking about how segregation
was sort of the original affirmative
action
but it worked the opposite way whatever
I'll I'll
[__]
I'll figure out how to do it although I
forgot to do that bit last night
um
maybe I'll [__] examine more of my
chicken humor on this all right here we
go oh my God Australia hey Billy you
dandelion [__]
why aren't you coming to Australia
run out of stupid jokes about us or did
you find your way into an Outback
Steakhouse and out of Fosters and
thought you got the point you dumb
American come make me laugh
um
can I be honest with you
[__] rejects from the English Empire
fellow Rejects
uh well you guys were just like [__]
animals that they couldn't control that
were like a bunch of criminals and then
they sent you to that lifeless [__]
Island
you call it country you can't even live
in like you know your bread basket is
like unlivable
um that's the AC DC song Highway to Hell
I always thought Highway to Hell was
them making fun of Zeppelin saying
Stairway to Heaven
Stairway to Heaven Highway to Hell
highway to hell was them driving through
the middle part of their [__] country
trying to get to a gig
um
but anyway yet nobody drinks Fosters
I've never seen it
um
you would think in a country of obese
people we would enjoy how big the can is
and all of that but it's just we know
what it is
it's you guys make unbelievably
delicious beer and you keep it for
yourselves like little creatures I can't
get that here
but your swill you basically put it in a
can the size of like a [__] PT boats
like depth charge and you send it over
here like right you'll eat it
you eat it you fat [__] right
um
I haven't been over there because I have
kids and I just I mean I just haven't
been able to [__]
figure it out I am going to get over
there and what's gonna suck is I have to
do you know what I should tour it in the
summertime which is your winter time
because then I can bring everybody over
there I just have to wait till my kids
get a little bit older and then I can
take everybody over there because I
don't want to go over there
because as much as I'm making fun of
your country I think it's a beautiful
beautiful place and you guys know if
you've listened to this podcast I am
[__] terrified of the ocean and I
have a buddy of mine that's over there
right now
who's saying how Sydney's his favorite
city in the world and he was talking
about the beaches and I have to be
honest with you is terrified as I am
of the ocean of sharks of the undertow
of hypothermia of being pulled out to
sea and just dying alone
and being out there on a moonless night
and not being able to see my hand in
front of my face and then feel something
touch my [__] leg as much as all of
that goes through my head
the beaches of Australia are so [__]
gorgeous
like I had to stop myself from going
into the water during the winter time
when it was cold I felt compelled to go
into it it was so [__] beautiful
I don't know why I have no idea why it's
the most okay
Australia most beautiful beaches in the
world
the most beautiful sea in the world is
the Mediterranean
okay
as far as my limited travel that's what
I feel so when I go to Australia I don't
want to [__]
go there and just Barnstorm it and start
off in Perth and then just work my way
back to [__] Sydney and right as I
get acclimated to the time I get on the
[__] plane and do 14 hours back
I don't want to do that I I like to go
there and enjoy Australia because it's a
[__] amazing country the people are
[__] hilarious
and last time I was there I want to say
I went to the um the Australian Open
the tennis event but I'd like to go
there
and like stay there like 10 days and
tour at a comfortable pace
and then maybe go to like Australian
Rules Football like actually experience
the [__] country
rather than just
coming into Melbourne and just checking
into the hotel and then you know doing
the gig and then [__] coming back I
don't want to do that so that's why I am
waiting I'm gonna come down there
all right I've been there like four
times and I will tell you one thing I've
never seen I've never seen anybody
drinking a [__] Fosters ever
never seen it and as far as Outback
Steakhouse how dare you
how [__] dare you suggest that I
would ever get a steak and a [__]
like that I listen I'm not gonna lie to
you Outback Steakhouse is a place I
would have gone to back in the day when
I was working in a warehouse
and I was [__] broke living week to
week but you know once you make a little
bit of money
okay
a state you just don't go out to get a
steak you save your money up and you go
to a place that's gonna make it right
all right and it's not a place that also
serves a bloom and onion whatever the
[__] that is although I've never had a
blooming onion it does look delicious
um as far as like
what the [__] was my steak place
steak was just never fast food when I
was growing up we didn't have Outback
Steakhouse we didn't have steak and
shake
who didn't have that and there also
wasn't a bunch of steak you know what
your mom made steak
and then she put it on the table and
your dad was like Christ you cut the
[__] out of it
my dad like he [__] the way he likes
steak it literally it was still almost
cold on the inside
anything else it was like Christ you cut
the [__] out of it
dude male female the [__] you could get
away with as a guy
back then
oh my God if my
the lovely knee every made me a a
[__] meal and I just whined it she
cooked the [__] out of it I would even
finish the statement before the [__]
meal would be over my head and then I
would be like yeah I deserved it like
what kind of an [__]
[Laughter]
you cook the [__] out of it um
anyway
but then my dad like undercooked
everything oh my God just undercooked
everything eggs runny as [__] hell
the worst is when he made [__] you
know poached eggs on toast the toast
would just be warm bread and then he
would [__] take the poached eggs out
of the skillet was not using you're not
using a slotted spoon because that was
the luxury so he put the runny egg with
whatever water was on the spoon onto
this wet warm bread
laughs
oh my God it was like
I don't even know I'm just immediately
thinking of like taking a steam
uh that's the level of water that was in
it all right explaining the angry
Sportsman podcast to my kid oh no
dearest Frederick freckles I listened to
your podcast for years in Australia this
is another Australian one all right [__]
it I'm going over there I'm Gonna Make
It Happen usually while I'm cooking my
family well usually I'm cooking my
family some dinner and my kids
oh my God okay so there's gonna be no
periods in this all right I'll do the
punctuation here let me read slower I've
listened to your podcast for years in
Australia usually while I'm cooking
usually why I'm cooking period
no usually while I'm cooking my family
some dinner
period
I'm gonna get rid of this and and just
say my kids have often asked why I
listened to this angry swearing American
talking slash screaming about sports U.S
Sports no less something literally none
of us care about whatsoever dude that
was my favorite thing
about jokic winning the you know
his whole after
like winning the championship and him
just clearly showing that basketball is
just a job and that he really just wants
to be back in his home country with his
friends hanging out with his horses like
which totally makes sense if you if you
can just get yourself out of like why
don't you think everything's awesome
in our country it's like
because he's not from here
and all of his memories and his friends
and all of that stuff and the pa the
pace of life and the food and all of
that
is back where he's from I thought it was
beautiful
he was just like you know oh you know
you're like you won the championship how
you feeling oh yeah that's great it's
great now he can all go home
and when he found out all the poor
bastard when he found out there was a
championship parade like three days
later he literally looked to the left
like well I got to do something else
what the [__] oh God
does anybody have video of him on that
[__] duck boat or whatever you take
him around in the the giant rubber raft
with wheels on it in um slash assault
vehicle in Denver I would love to see
footage of that
I bet he got off that thing and just
went straight to the airport and I hope
he got home as soon as possible and that
like uh just the way
you could just see how much he missed
his country and his friends
and his horses and all of that and I
just was looking at that like going oh
my God like when he looked over there if
I was the owner of the team I'd be like
hey man you know what you don't have to
go you don't have to go to the parade
just get get out of here
go home you know you won the
championship people aren't going to give
a [__] that you didn't go to the parade
I mean some will but that's just because
they're not happy with their own lives
um anyway
so they asked they're asking this this
guy this father
oh my God I gotta get eat some in here
my stomach [__] growling here why
he's listening to me he said I didn't
have a good answer for them but I've
always enjoyed the maniacal passion and
humor even when you're yelling about
something I have no idea about
well I appreciate that because I have to
be honest with you I can
I've watched clips of women yelling
about [__] to their guys in a language I
don't even know one word of I don't even
know how to say hello and I can
basically like I kind of understand
what's going on
and I can tell by his expression whether
she's a nag or whether he really [__]
up
and I can tell by her tone how close
they if this if this is the end of the
relationship or if this is just like a
moment
um
so that's cool that you can do that with
my I can't even I'm not even good at
speaking my own language so the fact
that you can [__] figure that out is
amazing
um so the guy goes on to say we all have
our interests and you're passionately
interested in things like drums music
Choppers Etc I think that's a good way
to be I'm in a family of music and art
nerds and we're all inspired and
passionate in the things we do too
however oh I taught my daughter her
first drum beat
and I'm taking my son to a music class
today
uh I'm very excited I'm just sort of
nudging him in that direction and if
they take to it then we're all gonna
[__] jam and I'll become the white
Joe Jackson and ruin their childhoods
kidding
um
no if they're into it they're intuitive
they're not then I'll just back off
so anyway the guy continues he says
however if the kid wants to skip Sports
at school
I couldn't give a [__] what does that
have to do him
I'm in a family music art nerds and
we're all inspired and passionate at the
things we do too however if the kids
want to skip Sports at school I couldn't
give a [__] well that's fine
he goes I'd rather they sat on the
sidelines with a fake medical
certificate I wrote clutching and Asthma
inhaler then risk injury or endure the
pointless exercise of chasing a ball
[Laughter]
it's got to be one of the best
criticisms of sports I've ever heard
simply because you've actually shown
that you're a passionate person and
you're into something else and here's
the thing
you know there's a lot of people that
don't like sports but everybody likes
music
you know what I mean everybody there's a
song that just gets you going I would
think I'm sure there's a couple of
exceptions but generally speaking and
you're into music so
um a pointless exercise of chasing a
ball
oh my God that's [__] amazing
I always I love people that aren't into
sports because I always want to be like
so what do you do with all your free
time
um
I'm literally addicted to it like I
actually have to go through a couple
days of like oh my God hockey and
basketball are over what am I going to
do and then I get into baseball and I
just I have to get totally into baseball
because if I don't then like what am I
going to do with myself
um all right so the person says I've
never cared for sports myself and I've
been relatively successful in life
dude you're cooking for your kids and
you're into music and if they don't want
to play sports you're okay with that
um you're an amazing human being and I
think you're a great father from what
I'm reading here
um
anyway uh he says I've given them full
permission to suck at Sports and care
less in recent years however I've gotten
into chess big time playing it watching
it following the great players all right
well chess is not a sport all right
let's oh my God that reminds me of
something I gotta tell you guys about
Chess has exploded recently online do
you know the world who the world's top
chess player is right now can you name
him
uh no I can't but I watched this story
recently and it's probably some guy
sitting in a park
um
but they're just not good at being in
the Matrix this person says maybe not
but the goat is a guy called Magnus
Carlson from Norway who's been blowing
everyone away for about a decade or more
uh I 100 can appreciate that I think
that's uh
I think chess and chess players are
actually fascinating like that level of
intelligence
um
and and like but my problem is watching
chess is like so [__] annoying
because it's either played over the
course of three days or it's played so
goddamn fast like I you know
it's like Eddie Van Halen speed and this
just is nothing for me to do because
Eddie I'm enjoying the sound he's making
and
when I'm watching chess players playing
as fast as Eddie
uh I I don't know what's going on so
it's just the sound of the [__] piece
hitting the board and then them slapping
the clock
and I'm like okay you guys you guys play
real fast
I don't know what the point of this is
um all right the way the young players
play now eclipses the last generation
since they all came up with computers oh
so they had to be good enough to be
computers
oh my God this gives me an idea for a
movie
ai's out of control
and then the only way to to to feed it
is they have to bring in a an
anti-social chess champion
that [__] hates Sports
and then he's around all these [__]
type A guys that played football at West
pointers I don't know I'll flesh it out
anyway I was watching the recent world
championship and found myself yelling at
the TV knowing all the backstory and the
drama following every move
well there goes my [__] Theory I
guess it is exciting every game and the
insane Underdog Story of the now
champion
and then I realized I am the angry man
yelling at sports now it's me I'm that
guy I finally get it well you're yelling
you're yelling at competition it's not a
sport though
um but that is pretty amazing
that's actually a really well written
email and it all came around and if I
didn't interrupt it with my own [__]
[__] that could have been a lot more
enjoyable for you guys so I apologize uh
he says thanks for everything you do I
thought we were very different but not
really I love your taste in music and
your Center
Center left humility in politics
uh keep banging those drums and much
love to the family
yeah there's a weird thing now like if
you're sort of in the middle
and uh like people get really angry
you know like when people trash Joe
Biden I'm like oh yeah that guy should
be out sitting on a porch somewhere he's
[__] horrific but having said that
these last two guys are the two worst
people that have ever been president and
then they get like upset and it's just
like
it's like this is the only way to the
light man
you just gotta you gotta be honest
okay they're they're [__] horrific
it's it's a [__] cartoon
it's a [__] cartoon
um anyway keep banging those drums I
will I'm going to play today man I
cannot [__] wait I can't wait I I
haven't
never enjoyed playing drums as much as I
am right now I am so inspired by just
like
some of the stuff that I've been
watching it's like going all the way
back
to uh oh Joey Castillo I think is the
guy that did the thing for um
Queens of the Stone Age that incredible
open-handed drum beat for uh Misfit Love
But like just watching stuff like that
all the way back to Tony Williams and
then of course my bottom [__] I've just
I've had so much goddamn fun I'm finally
just committing
to this Bebop book that I've always
wanted to have that jazz ride
Independence that I've just been doing
it every day and I actually find
playing jazz drums is just so much more
creative as far as like rock is just
really like
like mesmerizing repetitive
um in a lot of ways
like you you lay down that Groove and
the whole band is on top of it and
I just feel like with jazz drumming how
that that Foundation is on the ride
symbol and it opens you up to say all
these things between your hands and your
feet
um
at least how my brain is like I'm not
good at like improvising when I'm
playing like rock drums but like I feel
like jazz drums is like no this like the
music is improvisation
and I love that [__] because that's how
I like to be when I do stand up so it's
this weird thing where I gravitate
towards that style jazz drums but like
my DNA and the music that really moves
me that I feel is Rock drums rock music
or whatever so whatever
I guess I'm just trying to say that I'm
going to see Queens of the Stone Age
whenever they come through
[Laughter]
with John Theodore
um all right World economic
dear Billy brain juice
uh your constant ranting on the U.S and
World banking system is about to get
into I Told You So territory every week
more and more countries are leaving the
dollar and moving to the
y-u-e-n what the [__] is that I thought
Yen was spelled y-e-n I don't know what
that is or the b-r-i-c-s brics
international payment system Hey listen
we had a great run you know what I mean
Russia collapsed they're back
you know maybe we'll be back next time
we'll have a dictator that everybody
pretends is good at hockey
um Africa which has been largely
exploited by the West
uh of course raw materials and given
nothing and and Europe
just stop it already
just stop it already okay with this
[__] [__] we are Europeans
we're just living over here okay and now
you're trying to disown us uh for it's
raw materials and given nothing in
return
is making impact impactful relationships
and deals with China who will be giving
them something in return for exploiting
their raw materials the dollar isn't as
strong as it was in the U.S fed can't do
much more than keep raising Rage which
continues to bankrupt the middle class
yeah we're [__]
it what also [__] us was the way we
handled the fall of Russia
and we could have been these great
people instead we just went total greed
and tried to take it all for ourselves
so now Africa is looking at China
probably like they're better people when
they're not
no one is everyone has the same greedy
sociopaths running their country and
then underneath it is just a bunch of
[__] bald podcasting [__] like
me
you know trying to figure out how the
[__] you're going to survive their greed
that's essentially what it is
cheap bill could you oversimplify it
anymore well I'm a simple person all
right political economy studies
routinely show many of the US current
characteristics being a precursor to
economic collapse the only real hope
would be repurposed military spending to
fund education infrastructure at home by
all metrics we're the most propaganda
dies Democratic country in modern
history
hey well you know you got to give it up
to us when we go to do something we're
the best at it the hope is that one day
we elect Congress and a president that
speaks like an actual human being the
average no but the average gluttonous
unpatriotic American won't listen to a
rational person wax about how corrupt
the military-industrial complex is or
how we're being duped into handling over
privacy rights is is because a former
president is being prosecuted for
something other than killing millions of
people with drones
wait wait let me slow down here
the average gluttonous unpatriotic
American won't listen to a rational
person
talk about how corrupt the military
industrial complex is
or how we're being duped into handing
over privacy rights
is because a former president is being
prosecuted for something other than
killing millions of people with drones
or import sanctions on countries we're
not at war with yeah and you could you
could do that with
everyone back to Bill Clinton
they're all [__] guilty of that
killing millions of people with drones
and killing the wrong people and you
know war criminal Behavior
it just is what it is
and uh
uh yeah it's and if you say it then
you're [__] Un-American you need to
get out of the country and it's just
like no I I love this place and I'm just
watching a handful of [__] lunatics
take everything ah whatever this is too
[__] deep for this podcast and also
I'm not well read enough
all right the dollar
hey you pasty knuckle [__] you keep
saying that the dollar used to have gold
behind it gold isn't backbone of dollar
trust is
okay first of all are you Russian this
is a Russian bot gold isn't backbone
Abdullah trust is it is easier to trust
in Gold because you can see it measure
it at
measure it at because it is so rare it
has little surprises in it
but it is still just a mechanism you
have to trust that gold is worth
something yeah I understand that
uh I don't understand why money just
can't be worth something
you know
I think it's [__] I think that the
fact that they have to that the dollar
is worth less because they printed more
with no gold behind it it's just part of
the Banker's scam
to bring us to our knees so they can
have more that's what I think it is
because if we all believe in it
we all get paid in it then it should
have value
I mean I am as confused at that as when
the away team wins one of the first two
games and then they say they now have
home court advantage I still I don't
understand the math on that all right
trust can be gained other ways as well
and although you can't trust those other
methods others do and it makes the world
go around
uh the EU almost lost its mind when
Greece was going under Greece was losing
trust to handle its economy there were
so many big Banks going under it was
going to mirror on the whole of Europe
and especially Germany which is why it
was so eager to feed Greece money to
make it stable and trustworthy again now
Greece is recovering if the U.S would be
failing in similar fashion it would pull
some other country down it would pull
the world down it's not going to happen
so many I like this we're getting both
sides here it's going to happen it's not
so many countries would go under in
result that all those countries would
will rather pool money to secure USA's
trustworthiness it would result in
severe Cuts in the U.S spending but the
U.S would recover if trust fails on
different rules then we fall back on
gold if we can't trust gold then we will
trust food in the end food and water are
the real currency and that's why I have
a seller full of potatoes
I hope you have vitamins too greetings
from Finland there's no afterlife and
you can go [__] yourself
I love Finland man those [__] people
are amazing
they had they had the most profound
explanation of the afterlife I know I've
told this story before but for those of
you who are new to the podcast
I said so what is your guy's religion
over here
I can't even remember what they said I
said do you guys believe in an afterlife
and they were like no
and I go so what do you think happens
when you die and then this guy in the
crowd just goes
do you remember what it was like before
you were born
and I go no and he goes it's like that
and then they all laughed at me
[Laughter]
and I'm telling you
they that blew my mind I'm like it
really is that simple isn't it
there's really nothing to be afraid of
you're just gone
that's it
like a squirrel you're dead or whatever
but I don't know I've been taking
mushrooms over the last couple years so
now what I believe
is that nobody's I still believe nobody
knows what happens when you're gone but
um
my wife and her energy makes me believe
in a uh
I I would not like higher power I just
believe that like uh
I don't know there is something
there is something Beyond
what we're looking at but I I really
don't know what it is but I I am
definitely not going to try to find
those answers in organized religion
at all
um
but I will listen to any individual
I will listen to their Theory
from beginning to end the
but I'm not going to listen to people
that profit off of it all right oh Bill
oh gee you're so interesting go [__]
yourself you read [__] all right that's
it everybody that is the podcast go [__]
yourselves thank you for the emails
emails were really interesting this week
and uh
you know
um
I'm very humbled that people all the way
over in Australia are listening to this
podcast people in Finland and in
mainland China and all that type of
stuff okay
um you you're me don't let these [__]
Haberdashery [__] ever change that all
right [__] them
all right and get yourself a sandwich
I'll talk to you on Thursday